وينضم الينا من اكياس فيوريساك مستشار
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني اهلا بك سيد يوري
يعني فيما يخص
حزمه المساعدات الاوروبيه المنتظره بخاصه
الدبابات نتحدث والمدرعات كيف تخطط اكياف
لاستغلالها ومن الضمانات التي يمكن ان
تقدمونها كي لا يقع المحظور وتتطور الامور
الى الاسواق وهذه هي مخاوف المانيا
بالتحديد
نايمه
الدبابات هي لا ان اصبحت اولويه القصوى
للجيش الاوكراني لانه في هذه المرحله من
الحرب نحن بحاجه لمواصله تحرير اراضينا
بما ان النبي حاجه لمواصله عمليات الهجوم
المضاد الذي نقوم بهذه العمليات العسكريه
تحتاج
للدبابات الثقيله وقد
طالبنا بالحصول على الدبابات لفتره من
الوقت وكما شاهدنا في السابق من خلال اخرى
مثل
مارس وكذلك مدافع
والمداف الهاوزه راينا انه بعد ما تردد
حلفاؤنا الغربيون اتخذوا القرار في نهايه
المطاف ويجب ان نقر انه بالنسبه للمملكه
المتحده فقد فقدت القرار
بارسال همم دبابات
من طراز تشالنجر اثنين وسمعنا ان فرنسا
تنظر في اي ظن في تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات
هناك نقاشات بهذا الشان تجري حاليا نامل
طبعا انه خلال خير في قاعده رامز تايم قبل
بضعه ايام نعمل ان تحالف
الدبابات سوف يتم شائه من اجل مساعدته
همم اختراقات كبيره حصلت اثناء
اجتماعين بمعنى ان الجنود الاوكراني سوف
يبدا تدريبهم على استخدام الدبابات
الغربيين سوف يتخذون القرار المناسب كما
ان النواسقون بان تخويف بتصعيد هي
استراتيجيه خاطئه لاننا نتعامل مع بلده
ارهابي واذا راغبنا في تجنب والتصعيد هذا
يعني ان اوكرانيا تحتاج الحصول على كافه
الاسلحه التي نطالب بها حتى نستطيع هزيمه
روسيا على ارضي المعركه ونستعيد السلام
سيدي يوريك انا لينا بوك وزيره الخارجيه
الالمانيه بالامس همم فقط قالت ان حكومتها
لن تمنع بولندا اذا حاولت ارسال دبابات
الى همم اوكرانيا اليوم عندما وصلت الى
بروكسل يبدو انها احجمت عن اعطاء تفاصيل
وكانها كما فهم البعض تتنصل عما ورد
بالامس لم تكشف اذا كان هذا هو قرار
الحكومه ام لا ما الذي وصلكم من
البولنديين المتحمسين طبعا لارسال ليباد
ولكنه بحاجه الى اذن من المانيا ما الذي
وصلكم منهم تحديدا هل سيرسلون هذه
الدبابات قبيله المانيا ام لم تقبل وهل
تكفيكم اذا احجمت المانيا عن فعل ذلك
اود ان اقول انه غير ملائم بالنسبه لنا
انه عقب على سياسات وقرارات داخليه
لحلفائنا في البلدان الغربيه نحن نتفهم ان
بعض البلدان في اوروبا هي الان مستعده وقد
قال ذلك مستعد لتزويد هذه الدبابات الى
اوكرانيا بما فيها بولندا التي عبرت على
رغبتها في تزويد اوكرانيا
حتى وان رفضت المانيا
من المانيا انه لك مناقشات ايجابيه
بشان
انه في نهايه الامر شكرا
في اوروبا وهذا
جد كبير مقارنه بما نطالب به فنحن في
اوكرانيا همم نريد من هذه الدبابات ان
تلعب دور يغير قواعد اللعبه ونحتاج 300
دبابه وما هذا الا جزء من الدبابات
الموجوده علينا ان نتذكر ان الوراك
المتحده الامريكيه لديها الاف من دبابات
اي برامج
فقط 300 دبابه ولكن اذا اعطت البلدان
ارقام مختلفه فنحوى سنتمكن
بجمع جيش من الدبابات من اجل القوه
الاوكراني شكرا جزيلا لك مستشار وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني من كاف تحياتنا اليك